people are unfortunately
they need money it's the most wonderful
time of the year but it's also the most
expensive and many are doing anything
they can to make ends meet this holiday
season it's been much more aggressive
with the amount of people coming in Sean
Silber of Big Sean's buy and sell says
this year that unfortunately means
selling their things I've been in the
business 10 years now and this is
definitely the worst I've seen Silver
says with inflation reaching record
levels and housing prices still Sky High
a lot of people have to trade meaningful
things like wedding rings and family
heirlooms for cash and you're breaking
down which you'll pay this for and how
much you'll give this for and then
they're like let me keep the last item
just so I have one last memory of her
payday and title loans are also seeing a
10 to 50 15 uptick this holiday season
they have no option they need the money
today they're not thinking clearly of
what the consequences are going to be in
three months both options incredibly
difficult but in many cases necessary
just to get through when you need rent
or you need gifts for your child you got
to do what you got to do Sasha Loftus 8
news now Wilbur says one thing to keep
in mind if you have to make the decision
on whether to sell something or take out
a loan selling is better in the long run
so you don't have to worry about
payments or worry about interest